bonjour bienvenue dans le nouveau ces
caches c'est comme l'ancien mais sous
stéroïdes
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ces
caches votre émission s'offrent une
nouvelle formule nous recevrons
désormais un contributeur par mois pour
débattre avec olivier delamarche et pour
les quatre prochaines émissions c'est
vous véronique riches florès qui est
parmi nous merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté ce rôle vous êtes économiste
indépendante et présidente de riches
florès reasearch bienvenue puis dans ces
caches merci bonjour bonjour olivier est
à vos côtés évidemment olivier
delamarche bonjour olivier bonjour
estelle alors il ya eu les panama
peppers les paradise peppers place
aujourd'hui aux pandora paper c'est le
nom de la nouvelle enquête du consortium
international des journalistes
d'investigation sur les paradis fiscaux
et les sociétés offshore vous le vous
l'aurez compris c'est ce dont on va
parler je suis aujourd'hui mais d'abord
retour sur cette enquête et ces
révélations avec le tiroir cage
d'antoine basse
[Musique]
les pandores à petter se saigne nouveau
scandale d'évasion fiscale qui vient
d'être révélée après une enquête
journalistique
s'appuyant sur une fuite de plusieurs
millions de documents issus de sociétés
de services financiers installés dans
des paradis fiscaux des milliardaires
des célébrités mais surtout des
responsables politiques de différents
pays aurait eu ainsi recourra à ces
sociétés pour dissimuler avoirs et
transactions et échapper à des taxes on
trouve ainsi des personnalités bien
connues comme dominique strauss kahn
tony blair l'ancien premier ministre
britannique
les présidents équatorien
chypriote ukrainien et d'autres il y a
même shakira et claudia schiffer shakira
quand même le scandale est totale enfin
pas vraiment puisque finalement la
plupart de ces démarches d'évasion
fiscale je mets des guillemets qui
représenterait plusieurs milliers de
milliards de dollars seraient en fait
légal pour la plupart nous doit de faire
condamner les personnes incriminées l'aï
si hadji l'international consortium of
investigative journalist qui a sorti
l'enquète chercherait surtout à mettre
en évidence un certain décalage entre
les discours anti corruption de certains
politiques et leurs capacités parfois à
pratiquer l'évasion fiscale en france
cela pourrait permettre en tout cas à
bercy de récupérer quelques millions
avec quelques contrôles fiscaux bien
senti avec les panama peppers révélé
aussi par là ici hadji en 2016
la france a récupéré jusqu'à présent 126
millions d'euros avec 50 redressement
sur la base de samson 19 contrôles
fiscaux
olivier des sociétés off shore dans des
paradis fiscaux pour échapper à l'impôt
rien de nouveau sous le soleil
finalement non moi j'aurais plutôt
appeler sa fille poppée par ce parce que
franchement
ccc du plu au ridicule
c'est cette fuite probablement est
organisée par les services de
renseignements américains et anglais
qui se garde bien d'ailleurs de mettre
un sol américain dans cette liste comme
si c'étaient tous des oies blanches aux
états unis je rappelle tout de même que
1 dans la catégorie lessiveuse vous avez
plusieurs états américains
qui fonctionne très bien dont l'ancienne
et as de du président américain qui elle
de la mer donc arrêtons un petit peu ce
genre de plaisanterie ça vise en effet
des gens qui pour l'instant ne plaisent
pas au gouvernement américain et il
s'amuse à balancer ce genre
d'information si vous voulez la plupart
comme l'a dit antoine dans son dans son
tiroir cash
vous avez la plupart de ces de ces
opérations qui sont en fait parfaitement
légal et on pointe du doigt des gens qui
en est fait on avec un montage fiscal
acheter
divers actifs mais il n'y a rien de
nouveau sous le soleil et franchement de
temps en temps on vous montre ça pour
faire diversion et pour que vous pensiez
pendant ce temps-là pas à la hausse du
carburant ou autre chose je rappelle
quand même élevé qu'on ne sait pas d'où
vient cette chute que le consortium a
indiqué qu'il s'agissait d'une source
anonyme alors je vous le disais il y a
eu un fils et panama peppers il ya cinq
ans les paradise peppers un an après
l'open luxe l'enquète du monde sur le
luxembourg le journal qui qualifiait
d'ailleurs le pays de paradis fiscal au
coeur de l'union européenne en février
et aujourd'hui donc les pandora peppers
véronique riches florès qu'est ce qu'il
ya de différent cette fois dans cette
enquête ce nouveau il n'y a pas grand
chose de différent si ce n'est qu'
effectivement prend conscience se fera
en prend conscience on révèle
effectivement un système dans lequel
il ya probablement
incontestablement de plus en plus de
fuite
devant l'impôt de plus en plus de
correction et de plus en plus de
difficulté des gouvernements à avoir un
brin de contrôle sur ces masses d'argent
qui circule donc
j'entends bien ce que suggérait olivier
effectivement je pense qu'il a
probablement raison en tout cas on peut
recevoir son argument il n'en reste pas
moins que du point de vue de
l'économiste que je suis voire de la
citoyenne entre guillemets que je peux
être à mes temps perdu et bien on est
face à un vrai un vrai problème de
société
qui est le celui effectivement de
constater l'absence totale de de
contrôle sur ces masses d'argent alors
bien évidemment après à peu près dix
années de quantitative easing c'est à
dire d'injections de liquidités dans les
proportions qu'on a connus par les
banques centrales forcément moi j'ai
tendance à faire le lien entre les
effets de ces politiques monétaires sur
la circulation de l'argent
d'une ouverture extraordinaire des
frontières qui a certes quelques atouts
mais qui surtout permet des opérations
frauduleuses à des niveaux qui qui pose
quand même problème qui pose
incontestablement question et qui sont
des dangers pour les démocraties
voilà à titre d'exemple je citerai un
chiffre qu'on a peut-être pas en tête
aux états unis alors on n'est pas dans
les pandora où les panama pépin 5 mai
aux états unis vous avez aujourd'hui 30%
des transactions immobilières qui se
font en cash valises de cash
et pour la petite histoire j'ai même eu
personnellement mes pauvres hères qui
m'a proposé mais je t'achète ton
appartement je te paye cash bah moi dans
la petite tête de française musique mais
qu'est ce que je ferais avec une valise
de cash en france et voilà donc ça
dépasse quand même l'entendement mais ça
montre qu'effectivement tout se cache
qui circule est probablement pas
toujours très propre et ne vient pas
toujours d'endroits très très précis et
a pour destination
également des les endroits qu'on a du
mal à
suivre en tout cas alors est-ce qu'on
peut réguler et ça je crois pas vraiment
en tout cas pour l'instant il ferait qu'
un des dirigeants de la planète met un
gros coup de poing sur la table ou un
gros coup de pied dans la fourmilière je
vois pas lequel pourrait prendre ce
risque compte tenu des intérêts des uns
et des autres dans ces histoires alors
ce système dont on parle dans les bandes
aura peppers et le monde du off shore on
les appelle aussi lé société écran selon
l' ocde en 2019 onze mille 300 milliards
de dollars soit 10 milliards d'euros
étaient détenus dans des places offshore
olivier mise à part la non transparence
qu'offrent les sociétés offshore
initialement à quoi sert-elle
battu justement à
anonymiser leu leu
les intérêts économiques qui qui sont
dans ces dans ces sociétés c'est à dire
que c'est plus qu'une société anonyme
pour le coup elle est vraiment à nanning
et ça permet de 2,2 de mettre au bon
endroit et de d'extérioriser du résultat
au bon endroit c'est à dire à l'endroit
qui est le moins fiscalisés mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que c'est c'est
vraiment organisé par les états je veux
dire ça serait on pourrait simplement
arrêté au-delà ware ou dans d'autres
états comme ça de 2,2 permettre ces
fonctionnements et c'est blanchiment or
aujourd'hui je vous dis si vous voulez
blanchir de l'argent aller aux états
unis or les etats-unis se targue d'être
je vous dis plus blanc que blanc puisque
aucun aucun pandora ni aucun panama
peppers n'a touché un seul américain
vous n'allez pas me faire croire que
alors que ces états sont des
spécialistes des sociétés off shore si
vous voulez donc ne ne pensez pas une
seconde que derrière les mots il ya une
réelle volonté il n'y en a pas de
volonté sinon on l'aurait on les aurait
fermé depuis très longtemps et on aurait
empêché ça depuis très longtemps donc
c'est un espèce de double discours c'est
exactement le même contenu souvenez-vous
avec l'irlande l'irlande qui était une
organisation qui a été mise au sein de
l'europe pour justement défiscaliser les
entreprises qui quand elle de quantel
mettez leur siège ou en tout cas une
filiale en irlande permettait pas c'est
le résultat imposée à 7 8% et c'est
resté comme ça et c'était bien une
volonté
volonté de l'europe et volonté
plusieurs fois réafficher est maintenue
puisque au moment où les banques
irlandaises
on était en grave difficulté on les a
aidés mais on va pas demander de
contrepartie 1 on n'a pas demandé qu'on
relève les impôts à ce moment là donc
si on l'avait voulu on aurait pu on ne
l'a pas voulu et donc on a continué donc
tout ça sont des déclarations je vous
dis pour pour faire diversion et puis
pour continuer bien train tranquillement
les petites affaires en cours
les pandora paper sont tout de même mis
en évidence le dakota du sud comme étant
un paradis fiscal donc
l' enquête implique aussi les états unis
c'est tout à fait exact est-ce que vous
avez quelqu'un de citer américain non
non vous avez des gens qui gênent plus
tôt le le sofa peut-être pas shakira
mais
pouvoir américain mais la pop shakira
elle s'est fait prendre là dedans
c'était juste pour afficher un nom connu
mais mais sinon c'est sais je vous dis
c'est une blague est ce que vous pensez
sérieusement que demain le dakota du sud
va arrêter ses pratiques et qu'on va lui
faire arrêter ces pratiques n'ont pas du
tout ça va continuer comme avant donc
failli je crois qu'il ya vraiment c'est
du cedus et du marketing politique qui
roule pas autre chose les crèches les
reds est d'accord c'est du marketing
politique
alors je n'ai pas analysé comme ça mais
je dois dire que j'ai passé moins de
temps sans doute qu'olivier à décrypter
ce qu'il y avait dans ce rapport mais
on peut dire il me semble qu'à la suite
des pandora paper soudain d'un de ses
rapports on a fait une liste une black
list dans des états qui étaient à bannir
donc on voit bien que ces listes etc ces
actions politiques ne servent à rien en
l'occurrence et que ce sont des écrans
de fumée donc oui est-ce que alors est
ce qu'il ya une manipulation une volonté
affirmée j'en suis beaucoup moins sûre
en revanche qui est une
un manque de volonté ou tout simplement
une absence totale de l'attitude des
différents états pour faire pour stopper
c'est
ces phénomènes là j'en suis absolument
convaincu et rappelez-vous même même au
sujet de l'histoire de la fiscalité
minimale des entreprises quand la
présidente de la la première secrétaire
au trésor janet yellen américaine nous
dit il faut un plancher ou un taux
minimal d'imposition mais des états unis
ne peuvent pas l'imposer seul parce que
ce serait trop dangereux à cause de la
concurrence quand même les états unis
qui nous parle et on voit que même le
pouvoir américain est finalement
extrêmement réduit dans un monde où les
politiques ne contrôle plus rien ou
l'argent domine et et c'est là que
peut-être je suis un peu plus distante à
l'égard des propos d'olivier je suis pas
sûr tout cela soit manipulée réellement
ou ou guidées en réalité en deux temps
en temps il ya des rapports qui émergent
qui montre au grand jour un petit bout
de l'histoire parce que je pense que
c'est un tout petit goûter ces histoires
là qu'on nous affiche mais ça change
absolument rien effectivement c'est
systémique et pourquoi ne pas carrément
interdire les sociétés offshore est ce
que ça règlerait totalement le problème
cette interdiction par exemple non parce
que d'abord ce qu'il faudrait que tous
les pays qui jouent le jeu et tous les
pays ne joueront pas le jeu donc
finalement quand on regarde un petit peu
là la carte chacun à garder son petit
son petit paradis fiscal donc
et vous en avez aux états unis vous en
avez en chine où vous en avez
dans le restant de l'asie au cifa vous
en avait partout et donc
vous avez des discours en disant c'est
pas bien etc et puis derrière vous avez
des ddd pays qui fonctionne encore avec
avec ces paradis fiscaux donc je vous
dis enfin il n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas
on pourrait les interdire mais vous
aurez toujours une zone qui qui
fonctionnera qui continuera à
fonctionner comme ça et donc toutes les
sociétés qui ont fermé ailleurs iront se
transporter dans une autre zone et puis
c'est fait à partir du moment où vous
avez ce qu'on appelle la libre
circulation des capitaux partout dans le
monde et aujourd'hui il suffit d'appuyer
sur un bouton et vous faites tourner
trois fois
quelques milliards autour de la terre eh
bien vous ne pensez pas que vous allez
pouvoir arrêter ça parce que parce que
vous aurez toujours un pays qui va dire
oui mais enfin bon moi je garde mon
paradis fiscal je me fiche des autres et
à ce moment là vous allez avoir un
afflux de société qui va arriver qui va
arriver là bas donc il faudrait vraiment
une volonté politique des pays les plus
puissants c'est à dire les états unis
eau mais il se garde bien de le faire
puisque je vous dis ils en ont quelques
uns en leur sens à l'elysée on a tourné
vérifié pendant que vous parliez il ya
effectivement des américains cités dans
l'enquêté pandora paper des
milliardaires américains
très peu très peu mais comme les
européens vous avez quelques européens
vous en avais pas beaucoup et je pense
que si on veut aller regarder des gens
qui réellement
on des sociétés offshore etc il n'y a
pas que dominique strauss kahn alors je
pense que lui je le l'a fait c'était
assez connu il n'y avait pas besoin
d'attendre les pandora peppers pour le
savoir
mais vous en avez sûrement beaucoup
d'autres et qui sont qui ne sont pas
cités dans le rapport on va marquer une
courte pause nom revient dans un instant
bienvenue dans ces caches si vous nous
rejoignez au sommaire cette semaine les
pandora paper c'est aux côtés d'olivier
de la marche notre contributrice du mois
véronique riches florès économiste
indépendante et présidente de riches
florès reasearch véronique riches florès
3 6 336 à personnalités issues de plus
de 90 pays on l'a dit ont été épinglés
dans cette enquête on retrouve ainsi à
l'ancien premier ministre britannique
tony blair mais aussi le roi de jordanie
abdallah ii ou encore le président
équatorien guilherme ou la soul la
chanteuse shakira un mot peut-être sur
ce qui permet à ces personnes de
dissimuler leur fortune qui sont-ils et
est ce que par exemple c'est compliqué
aujourd'hui de créer une société
offshore non
je ne pense pas que ce soit compliqué
surtout quand on a de quoi justifier sa
création effectivement après
quels sont les conseils et les avis qui
permettent d'opérer de la sorte alors
écoutez je suis moi je suis pas dans les
petits papiers des spécialistes des
sociétés offshore et
mais vous avez dans ce type de dans ce
domaine et à deux conseillers de
spécialistes de la fiscalité
internationale et des des façons de
contourner surtout la fiscalité des uns
et des autres et je pense que ce n'est
absolument pas d'abord c'est un métier
qui probablement est encore très très
payant et très prospère et que c'est
probablement pas très difficile dès lors
qu'on a les bons contacts
malheureusement je peux pas vous en dire
plus puisque moi je n'ai pas ces
contacts et ce n'est pas en faisant de
la recherche macroéconomique
à l'aller une chance de connaître ce
milieu olivier
c'est assez simple vous avez des bébés
d'avocats internationaux en fiscalité
qui qui vous montre ça très bien très
facilement
et c'est fait c'est fait croyez moi en
quelques jours donc
c'est pas un problème mais évidemment
c'est ce que dit véronique c'est à dire
c'est c'est à la portée de gens qui ont
un qui ont des réseaux qui connaissent
parfaitement
les personnes chez qui il faut aller
pour faire ça mais vous avez vous avez
aujourd'hui beaucoup de monde beaucoup
de place qui font ça vous savez vous
savez très bien que par exemple dubai et
est un spot pour beaucoup de seins
d'influenceurs etc alors on essaie d
rattraper après parce que on a les
moyens quand même de leur expliquer que
toutes leurs activités fait en france
donc ça serait bien qu'ils payent des
impôts en france mais vous avez beaucoup
de 2,2 de deux spots comme ça et je
pense que ils sont suffisamment malin
pour se refiler les adresses des gens
qui vont la montée ça aux petits oignons
ou alors un mot à présent sur cet accord
trouvé à le 9 octobre dernier 136 pays
se sont accordés pour imposer une
taxation un minimum de 15% sur les
multinationales c'est à dire que chaque
pays pourra taxer à hauteur de 15% les
entreprises qui affichent au moins 750
millions d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
sur son territoire véronique riches
florès et est-ce selon vous un premier
pas vers un système fiscal plus efficace
alors juste pas du tout convaincu je
pense que c'est un pas très symbolique
en réalité et comme il fallait regrouper
le plus grand nombre possible de pays eh
bien ça s'est fait au plus petit
dénominateur commun 15%
on est très loin y compris de l'idée
initiale des états unis qui était plutôt
à 21% de mémoire on est loin également
de scorer souhaitait la france 25% on
est beaucoup plus proche d'eux
des exigences de l'irlande par exemple
et
le risque de tout ça c'est pas que ce
soit que ces 15% constitue un premier
pas une espèce de socle à partir duquel
les uns et les autres ajusterait à la
hausse une fiscalité c'est plutôt que ça
tire à la baisse les taux de prélèvement
des entreprises dans beaucoup de pays
puisque de toute façon s'alignera sur ce
minimum et voilà alors le risque
effectivement c'est que s'appauvrissent
certains états et pas forcément les
états les plus riches mais parmi des
pays moins développés je pense que c'est
une source de difficultés qui peut se
profiler est fine et j'ai plutôt
l'impression moi que ça valide un
système de très faible imposition sur
les bénéfices des entreprises à
l'échelle mondiale les lieux est
d'accord oui d'autant plus que c'est
très symbolique ce taux de 15 % parce
que ça porte sur quoi c'est la base
imposable qui est important et donc
balancer un chiffre comme ça si vous
voulez sans qui est derrière de règles
sur justement comment on fabrique ce
bénéfice imposable et quelle est la base
d'imposition
c'est juste c'est juste de la com
merci olivier merci beaucoup véronique
riches florès d'être intervenu dans
cette émission je rappelle que vous êtes
économiste indépendante et présidente de
riches le res reasearch on se retrouve
la semaine prochaine olivier nous on
reste ensemble pour les questions et
commentaires cash
et on démarre avec le commentaire de mox
95 l'immobilier qui ne rentrent pas dans
le calcul de l'inflation on explique
comment ils rentrent dans le calcul
l'inflation mais il est sous sous
pondérer dans le calcul de l'inflation
c'est-à-dire que ils rentrent mais tout
le monde sait que il consacre 30 ou 40%
de son de ses revenus à son logement et
et le dans le calcul de l'inflation
l'immobilier ne rendent que pour un
faible pourcentage donc
pourquoi tout simplement parce que
c'est une manière de sous-évaluer
l'inflation comme d'autres alors on vous
a expliqué comment on pouvait justement
sous sous-évalué cette inflation parce
que c'est un chiffre qui est aussi un
chiffre de marketing politique dont
complètement le calcul de l'inflation
le calcul de l'inflation n'est pas le
calcul du coût du coût de la vie ça n'a
rien à voir
si vous prenez un vrai fâche dire
r111 coût de la vie recalculées
vous êtes plutôt sur une hausse
régulière de entre 5 et 6% que que ce
qu'on vous annonce comme étant
l'inflation qui étiez depuis assez
longtemps en dessous de 2 donc oui c'est
un faux chiffres merci olivier c'est la
fin de cette émission merci de l'avoir
suivi prochain rendez vous la semaine
prochaine en attendant pour voir ou
revoir nos précédentes émissions rendez
vous sur notre site internet à l'adresse
rt france point tv et n'oubliez pas
cette émission sur les réseaux sociaux
avec le hashtag rtcs h olivier c'est à
vous pour le mot de la fin est bien
quand le sage montre la lune le crétin
regarde le doigt ne soyez pas les
crétins